So to wrap up our discussion of hydroxy chloroquine
and how after a number of studies showing
it's not helping patients and in fact may
be hurting, Trump is no longer talking about
it.
Fox News is barely talking about it.
Both Dr. Phil, who is a psychologist, not
a medical doctor, and Dr. Oz, who is a medical
doctor but is widely known for promoting quack
cures.
Both of them have been saying anti-science
things about the virus.
But Dr. Oz has been particularly present as
a propagator of chloroquine miracle treatment
type nonsense for many weeks now.
We now have a study I told you about from
the V.A. which says this isn't working well.
It might be hurting patients.
Now, credit to Fox and Friends.
They actually did a story this morning about
that study and they brought on Dr. Oz.
Let's take a look.
All right.
So let's move on to hydroxy chloroquine.
They did a study, Illumina study at a V.A.
hospital, and they came to the conclusion
it did no benefit and they still had 19 deaths.
What's your reaction to that since you've
been doing?
We've all been doing heavy work to find out
where if this works or not.
So I hate to already be jumping in so quickly,
but Brian KILMEADE is already rewriting history.
Brian KILMEADE says we've been doing heavy
work to find out if this works or if it doesn't
work.
No, dude, you've been promoting the drug just
like Trump has.
Now that it's not working, he's rewriting
history to say we've been investigating with
an open mind.
Maybe it works, maybe it doesn't.
Now, that's not what you were doing.
You're rewriting history.
Let's now go to Dr. Oz.
Well, this study looked at older and quite
a bit of sicker patients, all in all male
patients in their hospitals.
And they show that the drug by itself didn't
help and might harm that population.
As you know, there've been other studies done.
This deviously was retrospective.
They looked back to see what had happened
because they weren't getting the data at the
time that they were actually giving them medical
medications.
Studies that have done this prospectively.
So looking forward and giving it as they as
collecting data as they're going along like
in France or the randomized trials from China
have shown benefits, but only really when
it's given.
Earlier to patients.
So Dr. Oz mentions all the reasons we might
not be able to trust this new study.
It was only male patients.
Well, that's actually good in most good studies.
You look at only men or only women to eliminate
sex as a possible factor that affects the
results of the treatment.
It was retrospective.
Well, many of the studies that are being done
are.
But the most disturbing thing is that Dr.
Oz mentions that French study.
The French study Dr. Oz mentions as a counterpoint
had under 40 participants and no control group.
The V.A. study at least had close to a sample
size of 400.
And again, Dr. Oz could just tell the truth
and stay and say every study so far has had
some issues.
But this is a bigger study and it doesn't
look good.
Instead, Dr. Oz says, well, you know, you've
got this study and you've also got the French
study with the 36 or the 38 patients with
no control group.
And he says that one looked good, even if
this one doesn't very dishonest.
He also mentions studies from China that look
good.
I won't even comment on that now because later
in the segment, Oz himself says, We really
need data from the United States.
If we need U.S. data, why even bring up the
Chinese study?
Now, in this next segment, he actually does
say the right thing, which is what I've been
saying all along.
The fact the matter is, we don't know.
Thankfully, these these medications are prescription
only.
So doctors are desperately awaiting the completion
of the higher quality randomized trials.
And we've you've covered them on the show
several times.
South Dakota University, Minnesota, now has
over a thousand patients randomized.
There's additional trials going on.
Let's get that data so we know what we're
dealing with.
So that would have been the right thing to
say all along, which is we just have to wait.
Dr. Foushee said we need randomized controlled
trials until we have those we really don't
know.
That's what they should have been saying from
day one.
A little bit more here where Brian KILMEADE
introduces the Z pack element, which may actually
make the treatment even more dangerous.
And Dr. Oz, just white flags and says we've
really just got to wait for the r-s.d.
And just to follow up pretty quick.
So let's show it.
Just isn't is it important to know what they're
combining it with and the dosage because it's
not supposed to be taken on its own.
Don't you have the zoback?
There's a lot of variables, Brian.
I got to say, I think at this point, there's
so much data coming from so many places, we're
better off waiting for the randomized trials.
Dr. Fouche, she's been asking for otherwise.
This is what we keep reacting.
We'll be going back and forth for studies
that show opposite results.
And a lot of it might have to do with when
you get the medication, if you give it to
people, you're are already having breathing
tubes down your throat.
And it's not going to have the same kind of
effect as if you give it early.
But we don't have good randomized data from
the United States to educate us well enough
right now.
So, again, if Dr. Oz had said this on April
1st, I would be praising Dr. Oz.
I would be saying, hey, you know what?
When Trump was promoting it and you had just
this French study to tout, even though it
had 38 people in it, if then Dr. Oz said,
she's right.
We've just got to wait.
I would I would have respected him from day
one.
Instead, Dr. Oz and Fox and Trump have all
been promoting this.
And this would have been the thing to say
then, rather than to spend three weeks promoting
it, only to now say, you know, you really
need randomized controlled trials.
It's pathetic.
And with every passing day, hydroxy chloroquine
is a word that is harder and harder to find,
both coming out of Donald Trump's mouth and
coming out of Fox News broadcasting.
Really pathetic.
We've been saying it from day one and they
actually have been spreading dangerous disinformation
all along.
We'll have more about this change in tact
when it comes to chloroquine on The David
Pakman Show Instagram page.
Make sure you follow us on Instagram at David
Tak
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.